[Music]  george r.r martin please write and write  faster you're not going to get any  younger you know  winter is coming i'm growing impatient  and you still got two whole damn books  left to go  so write george right like the win  [Music]  i curse the day that my friend ever  loaned me  an old dog-eared paperback called game  of thrones  how could i know that this seed would  grow into  an addiction that held me right down to  my bones  now five months later  entitled and waiting for a word that the  great bearded glacier has  finally published mine hundreds or pages  of  wrecks  okay pull storm  george r.r martin is what  he's he's known  i can't hear you  he's not our [ __ ]  now you remember that clean this mess up  like good boys  sorry neil gaiman